obviously this doesn't go fair for
anyone using a windows computer
like that's several steps away just
throw it out what you want to do is is
if you take your computer and go out
with your back door
open up the recycling just put it in
there
speaking of 170 bpm music french core
is the one to call for anyone that
enjoys
a bit of kind of edm music and things ah
but
i just wish it was just twice as fast
and a bit
it is another life hacks episode tools
techniques and tactics for a productive
and efficient life
if you haven't seen this before we do a
roundtable each of us proposes
some sort of life hack we've come up
with over the last few weeks since the
previous episode
and then the other two tear it to pieces
or immediately proclaim that person is
god
and say right i'm gonna go buy it or i'm
gonna start doing it right now
and uh and that's it that is it
or there's the delayed reaction which is
proclaim the others as an idiot and then
a couple of years later we're all
doing that thing we're all moving in the
same with the same direction at once
uh if you want to check out whatever it
is that we talk about there will be
links in the show notes below if there
are discounts or
codes or whatever i'll have trolled the
internet and tried to find them so
if there's something that you enjoy that
you want to go and use just
look show notes below comments below and
uh they'll be there
so johnny you're first up there's a hot
potato for you
oh get in the face right
so i'm i think what we just spoke about
there is like the true test of a life
hack is when someone said it
two years ago i make fun of it and then
i say it again and i'm a bit worried
about this one
i don't think it's been mentioned before
but it's the sort of thing that chris
would have recommended
so and i would have probably made fun of
it as well okay
so let's see it's something that um
dan digital audio broadcast actually
recommended to me
um which is i really struggle
so on the i don't know what you remember
last time i spoke about struggling with
creatine
and i creatine tablets solved that
problem for me yeah
i also struggle with morning whey
like having a whey protein shake in the
morning
i just find it a bit i don't know like
it's never quite what you'd expect it to
be
clear away from my protein
is excellent this is a more kind of
juice consistency compared to the
milkshake type
yeah so yeah one scoop in water give it
a shake leave it
it's very important to leave it because
if you go for it away
if you go for it straight away so like
my first like week of experience with it
was like
semi-congealed it's it's hydrolyzed way
so semi-congealed bits of hydrolyzed
whey
it was like this is awful but then you
leave it for
two three minutes and it's just like a
juice so as a morning
as a morning supplement brilliant so
that's my life hack
so it's a hydrolyzed waste so it's not
an isolate
yeah so i thought it was an isolate but
if you read the ingredients it does say
hydrolyzed way maybe some methodology
has come
so far in the last few years like for
hydrolyzed way
because back in the day pre you know if
you've heard of the fitness menopause
podcast we're back where we were you
know deep in the days i know chris you
mentioned like
where you my protein was just like a
build it yourself
powder and you could literally put in
like the most stupid combinations of
like i want 95 percent beta-alamine five
percent
horny goat weed yeah yeah only goes
beautiful waxy may start
with a minging absolutely disgusting and
all of these like
you'd get casein which was just like
basically a lump of sand that as soon as
water touches it it becomes a solid and
you shake it in your thing and it just
goes
in you yeah and so what's idealized way
what's the advantage
of this journey less digestive
discomfort better taste
sort of less of a bloated feeling so
maybe you two don't get this but like
when i make a protein like you make a
protein shake like a scoop or two scoops
of
whey concentrate with like water from
the tap
it's always this like six out of ten
experience isn't it like it's
you never like oh god i'm glad oh that
was delicious
i'm really glad i had that first thing
and then you feel a little bit googly
and you're like
i don't feel that great about it but the
the
the clear way just tastes like juice so
if you get like the orange and mango one
for example
it just tastes like having orange juice
in the morning and it's but it's
20 i think 25 grams of protein or
something so it just
i think it just makes it easier so i do
that and then i have that with my
creatine tablets and my supplements it
just makes it easier to like
it's something i always do because i
like the taste of it and it's effortless
and it tastes like juice what is the
what are the flavors that you've tried
and what is the
optimal powder to water ratio
great questions chris great question so
i have tried watermelon
grape rainbow candy wow you've been
you've gone very deep into this did you
get sample packs or are these all
legitimate ones that you've worked my
way through
i went full full container wow um wow
yeah um okay did i say watermelon
peach tea and then the mango one
and i think probably the the map i think
the watermelon is my favorite
one i think um and it's one scoop
with quite a bit of water come on
come on well it depe what you want the
amount of water yeah
so they're on those metal shakers yep i
do
i know they have like milliliter marks i
don't pay attention to that i do about
three quarters full
three quarters full with one scoop with
one scoop
the water in first then the scoop in
shake it leave it
this is very important you cannot stress
that enough you must leave it
and then come back to it let it let it
prepare itself come
back to it in two three minutes and you
have a tasty juice protein drink
so there is an argument that you should
have
tasty protein supplements because that
induces the caphalic phase of digestion
it gets your digestive juices going
it helps you absorb the protein better
compared to
back in the day when we would just pound
like unflavored hydrolyzed whey that
just tastes
a vomit because it is vomit chemically
it's it's pre-digested
protein so it's got that vomity taste
so now like there's no excuse is that
you've got
peach tea watermelon i think my my
flatmate got me some sample packs for my
birthday i think of this type of way
and it was like a limited edition
refreshers flavor
palmer violets um like all these mod
flavors
great i love it that's really cool
anyone that wants to go and get that the
code modern wisdom will get you 37
off or greater on everything at my
protein if you go to bit.ly
slash modern wisdom there's a link in
the show notes below just go and get it
if you want to check out this clear way
we hadn't organized that but thanks
johnny
that's either of you tried it no i'm
gonna i'm gonna i've got my it's this
third of april so my account allowance
will have been restocked and i'm going
to get
one of whatever your top few flavors are
you'll love it chris i think yusuf i can
imagine drinking going
and then being really annoyed about it
because it is quite expensive that's the
only downside
is what it is you seth what have you got
for us
so on take two of the intro of this
podcast you guys asked me
is this t-shirt yours and they both you
clicked that it wasn't because it
fits well and it's a good choice of
t-shirt and you know me well enough to
know that my
fashion sense is terrible so my
life hack is whenever you wear a piece
of clothing
use it as a chance to be like because
very few people have got too little
clothes i think clothes are
unreasonably cheap and usually we hold
on to just crap
t-shirts or whatever that we have just
because status quo
so let's use it as a chance to be like
do i really want to wear this in the
future or was this just a decision that
past me has made that i no longer agree
with
and so now whenever i put on a t-shirt
or a
sock or something i'm like hmm could
this be the last time
that i wear this and i know that there's
some kind of
um psychology so i mean case in point
here's my bin with a t-shirt in it
um and it's a rubbish t-shirt i'm not
gonna miss it i bought it maybe
10 years ago in primark so the
was it something you said about the
level that you value
things that you already have is
different to if you were to
buy it for the first time or if you were
to lose it and you want it back
and our brain plays these funny games to
value things differently and you have to
kind of get objective and be like no no
if i didn't own this right now
would i actually go out and buy it or
would i be like no it's worthless to me
is the value only because it's already
mine
that's cool that's like a evolution
of the fittest clothing
survival survival of the fittedist
i have a i have a slight variant on that
that i've actually done over the last
year i think so i think i might have
mentioned this on my lifehack before
but um which is i
moved basically all of my clothes
onto like a separate rail in the hangar
and every time i wore something i put it
on a different rail
and after a six month period everything
that isn't
on the main rail
just get rid of oh so you're doing the
same thing but in batch
well it's just the process of like
formalizing the formalized process isn't
it
no i think hey i think this is awesome i
i have done it a different way so i've
been
taking big blocks of clothes to a buddy
and um he does a lot of ebay stuff
and i just said look if you want to list
these on ebay
take 50 of whatever they make it was
either that or the charity shop
i tell you what's mad i didn't even
thought of this but the amount of money
that you will get
for worn but good condition training
shoes
i go through a lot of pairs of nanos and
metcons back in the day before
the reebok deal and stuff and um
yeah they're still getting a
three-year-old pair
of worn but in all right conditioned
shoes will still get 25 or 30 pounds
and then physicists just love worn shoes
don't they
i'm not sure that it's all fetishists
because you don't know who's worn it is
it surely is part of the fetish not
knowing the person that wore it and
thinking about them wearing it
it's not just a dirty shoe is it you
have heard the story about
when i was in that flat haven't you yeah
i don't even know what episode that was
in
very very early on why don't you tell it
again okay
one day i was living in edinburgh in a
flight of a few people
student flat and this guy came to the
door and he had his hair like slicked
back and he was in a shirt
he looked a bit [ __ ] and i was like
hello and he was like oh hi um i'm here
for the shoes
we were like i don't know he was like
it's simon
and i was like yeah and then someone
else walked past and i'm like
hello do we know you just thought i'm
just looking for some and then sam came
out
oh you're right mate yeah um you're here
for the shoes yeah no problem here you
go
and then we were like oh can you just
explain what's
going on here and he was like well
if you must know i have a foot fetish
and
i've would really appreciate the the
shoes and
and we were just like okay fine then
after he left we were like sam are you
not
bothered that there's a man who's
probably doing unspeakable things to
your shoes right now and he was like
no that's fine like if he gets more joy
out of them then great basically this
guy had followed him
like a week before and asked him for his
like dirty shoes which were
in terrible state and he was like well
yeah you can have them but
i need them until wednesday when i get a
new pair so just come back on wednesday
and i'll give you them
so that does sound related to the person
i've also gotten quite a lot of effort
in fact to find that guy's shoes
specifically yeah so maybe that's just
what
is what's happening across issues maybe
maybe yeah i don't know what i'll do
seller i'm i was going to say i'm one
level removed because someone's
arbitraging my shoes
right okay uh my first one for today is
youtube premium i've either of you two
got youtube premium
so i've done the trial for it and didn't
continue with it
okay i know i know that you have
won't have done no i've been recommended
it and i
can't see the appeal so george is a big
proponent of youtube premium couldn't
believe that i didn't have it
um i'm really open to getting it so sell
it to me chris
okay so i decided it was michaela
peterson
when we always say this and this is a
this is a life hack for life hacks right
everybody that is listening if multiple
different people come to you with the
same suggestion
independently just just do it because
the the likelihood of the stars aligning
in that way
specifically for people in separate
social circles to come to you and say
you really should try this
so george had done it but that was just
one then
michaela couldn't i think i sent her a
screenshot of something i was watching
on youtube
and she noticed by the the top bar that
it wasn't youtube premium
and she said i can't believe that you
don't have youtube premium you need to
as
right right i will buy it so uh upgraded
for the most part i use i use youtube
quite a bit i also
watch lots of content that i could just
listen to
also trying to reduce my screen time and
all of that combined
means that no adverts is saving me at
least
10 seconds to 15 seconds per video i
think they've youtube have pushed the
limit for the unskippable section of an
ad now to between six and seven seconds
which is very cheeky of them
um and then so i'm i don't ever have to
skip ads
i can swipe up and go on to other apps
or i can just lock my phone and leave it
somewhere and listen to what's going on
so a lot of the time when i'm doing
podcast prep for a guest
brian green who's this super famous
physicist last night
i just left the phone on the side and
listened to him and neil degrasse tyson
talk
but it's easier to find something on
youtube than it is on apple podcasts or
spotify so a lot of the time actually
youtube's is simpler because the search
is more optimized
it's better to listen to stuff on there
it's just a problem of having to watch
it at the same time
having to stay on your phone to skip the
ads so skipping ads is a huge one being
able to play
uh while it's off you get free access to
youtube music i haven't even downloaded
it i don't need it
um it is not that cheap when you
consider that a netflix subscription is
what for the four person ultra hd it's
maybe 14 pounds a month now
and i think youtube premium is 12 to 13
pounds a month
so it's not it's not cheap but i mean
scale up how many videos do you watch
per day how much time do the adverts
take from those videos
it's easy i'm easily roi positive on it
uh plus
i don't have to use my phone so i am now
a youtube premium convert so it's
ad-free
it is you can close the app and listen
to stuff can you save stuff offline yeah
can you have like
yeah use case for that would be super
minimal it would only be when i was
maybe on a plane or
traveling somewhere abroad but that
would be nice there's some extra
features that you get
um another thing is that you you buy it
and it attaches to a particular
account so let's say that you guys
bought it for the
propane fitness channel you would
actually both be able to benefit so long
as you were both using the propane
fitness channel as opposed to what i
presume you both have which is a
personal one outside of that
so i bought it but me and video guy dean
now have access to youtube premium on
the chris williamson
main channel so yeah
what do you think johnny are you sold
well so it links quite nicely with my
next life hack
ah it's just it's seamless we're into
slow it's as if we prepared but we
haven't
haven't yeah yeah um should i just go
into that then
so i have been
training in my garage which means i
when i log my training so that i don't
have to like be relying on my phone all
the time
i use my laptop so i just fracking
pictures even worse
because that's where all my work is but
so like i have to track a lot of stuff
which i don't know benefit all this is
why johnny can no longer train in a
public gym
because i've got too much stuff with me
yeah i've got basically a portable lab
vr headset barometers yeah yeah
um but so something that i've found and
i can't explain why
but i if i'm listening to music when i'm
training
or if i if i'm just like training on my
own and i'm listening to normal music
it's like 75 benefit but if i listen to
a live version
of the music like if i listen to a live
band performance or a live dj set
there's something even though the audio
quality is worse there's something about
that like
live experience the energy yeah
it's brilliant but obviously all of
that's on youtube
so having a like
because there's nothing more annoying
than like
unwrapped the bar and then grammarly has
and that has happened so many times to
me like the mid-roll
like and it's they're always the the
most intrusive as well like there's
nothing more contrasting
than bear have you thought about live
life insurance policy yeah
yeah another thing aggressive set and
then it's an ad about something
completely separate
so i like it autoplay continues
outside of when the app's closed so
it'll still continue to auto play even
when your phone's locked
which is nice so you could create a
little playlist and it'll run through
the playlist
i get what you mean about the live thing
does your live music have to have crowd
noise in
yeah i think so yeah i would agree live
music without crowd noise is just a
poorly recorded normal album track
well so that yeah so there's a few
there's a few instances like over the
last year
when bands and djs have done live sets
but there's no crowd
and it's worse it's way worse
even though they already the audio is
better than a like a recorded live at a
venue
but if it's live at a venue like there's
some like karang
for anyone in like metal music i've done
a series in
what they call the pit the cape is the
islamic holy book
[Music]
exactly yeah they organized um
some gigs in a bar and it's the audio is
terrible but the atmosphere is great and
those those are
awesome give us um give us what are the
three most watched videos live music
videos
that you've gone to for training on
youtube
i mean it's very like the number of
people who hear my recommendation and
think like that sounds good but
they'll be like three and one of them
will be you chris doesn't matter tell us
architects live at reading what
uh i think it'll just be the most recent
one okay
um bear tooth at uh
whacking festival and
like anything by like you'll hate this
chris like skrillex steve aoki
martin garrix anything like that
anything like very like edm like very
lots of crowd noise lots of uh three two
one jump three two one
left yeah
i mean to be honest as well like some of
the power lifting or like
lifting motivation videos as well as
cheesy as they are
they're good as well if you need to
really pull a lever on something
something like that can be quite good as
well that's cool man there you go
hey i am i've been watching reggie faso
who is
one of the jst athletes he's just come
third in the uk
in the the open uh came sixth in the
world
in the uh 21.2 workout
monster the guy the guy's a freak but
the stuff that he listens to that those
guys listen to
as they're getting ready to send it uh
like is it ian vandal castles in the sky
but but like a 170 bpm gaba version
or like some german techno youssef's
nodding along quietly they're 170 bpm
that's your sort of [ __ ]
beautiful but uh yeah i think
i think one thing that's been lacking
definitely over the last year there's
just been no reason to send
anything it's been such a low energy
year generally you haven't really been
laughing with friends
send anything what's up yeah sending it
so what why what if what's the reason to
get excited about
really any i go and do a session on the
bike in my kitchen
oh yeah really gonna get myself excited
for this to move
the five meters from my living room to
my kitchen so that i can get on the bike
for
and do steady state for half an hour um
and the opportunities to kind of give
yourself some energy extrinsically by
putting some good music on with crowd
noise so it's like these are
this is my ten thousand fake friends for
today and um yeah
they've joined you when you in your
garage is your lifting
i think that's for those who know how
much that we we like to kind of
bounce energy off each other as humans
yeah well i something i'm aware of at
the moment is like
the i've still got the 10 available to
add on to my session by just like
being in a gym with other people so you
know like a session that's hard
add a bit of music on add a bit of
atmosphere caffeine feel really good
it's going to be like it's still only
going to be 90
because if i did the same thing at a
meet or a busy gym
it's it's always going to be better
there's always that extra little bit to
pull which is cool so that's exciting
for when suffering opens again
live music for training i like that yeah
live music general can't wait to go to
something live uh
what have i got what have i got tickets
for i bought tickets for
uh abgt 450 with
anjuna deep the next day i think it's at
the dockyards or something in london
um that's good there's still tickets
available if you want to come uh george
me and george mac have bought tickets
for it
um but yeah it's in september are you
adding it to omnifocus
yeah beautiful beautiful uh but yeah
that's going to be sick that's the first
thing that i've got booked in
um it's in september i still don't know
if it's going to happen
if we don't go and see bring me the
horizon in september chris i will be
inconsolable it's already sorted you
know ollie's bought a house with his
misses in brazil did i tell you this
yeah olly sykes bought a house in brazil
with his missus so he sold he flogged
his one in sheffield one with the gym
and
and the pool um so he flogged that one
and now
he was like uh just they were out there
in brazil
and he couldn't come back and if he'd
come back you'd have had to stay in a
hotel and do all of this thing
and uh now there's like moved that what
he's just
they bought a house i'll just buy a
house and then if i need to
like we'll just keep it i guess that's
what happens when you've got [ __ ]
money isn't it
um yeah just like it's easy to just buy
a house
ridiculous man honestly watching
watching the guys and this is on their
public stories on instagram so everybody
else
that follows bring me the horizons
bandmates knows this but
like matt nichols the drummer
will spend days like
re-pointing the brick work
in in his conservatory
because they're just such working-class
sheffield blokes that happen to be world
famous rock stars
like you don't really think about
another aussie osborne
or you know aerosmith you don't think
about them doing the pointing
in their conservatory but yeah i i
there's something i quite like about
that
well it's when like you could easily pay
someone to do it but there's something
rewarding about
doing it yourself yeah i know right it's
doing about choice isn't it what are you
doing
this is on the back of the youtube
premium so i've
i heard your sales pitch and i raise you
an alternative method just because
for me none of those features hit my
pain points to
to sign up for youtube premium partly
because i don't really use my phone so
the idea of being able to play a video
with the screen off compared to the
screen honest like kind of irrelevant
to me um so what i
do for youtube is everything's done
entirely through alfred
you can search and then find a video
within alfred so that's like the app
even your browser doesn't have to be
open
and then you can play it through a
media player called ina iina
so you can just play any url any
playlist it
remembers the spot that you were in last
time
along the video you can adjust the speed
and skip forward and back and stuff with
the keyboard shortcuts
it doesn't buffer it just loads the
whole thing and then you can just play
it as if it's like a
video that you've downloaded and it's
generally just a lot less intrusive
there's no adverts i haven't seen an
advert in
years because because i use brave which
is the
life hack from a few a couple of years
back probably now so
my recommendation would be just get
alfred properly set up
figure out all of your use cases even if
it's stuff that like watching youtube
you think it that wouldn't be an alfred
fix for it there probably is so
start with my youtube video and then
just browse the
alfred repository and you will have a
lovely time the problem
with alfred is it's like a it's a blank
canvas with a really nice
set of paints and like you've got you've
got the potential to create something
brilliant but you could also do like a
smiley face stick man like you've got to
know what you're doing
you've got to know what you're trying to
create that is such a good analogy yeah
yeah he so youssef tried to give me some
sort of workflow
macro workflow thing for alfred sent me
at the other day
um so that i can search my notes because
i've got 2 000 notes on apple notes
and yousef sent me some workflow i
pressed a button and then what what came
up that i i didn't have that the python
css
that existing library module to plug it
in and i was watching the genesis of a
scoby problem
occur in front of my eyes i'd been
infected with it i was seeing it the the
was it a prometheus that i was watching
the prometheus
vizio evolving from the embryonic state
that's into
the fully fledged alien yeah whenever
that happens and like the sore music
plays you know when he's going like i'd
like to play a game and it's
like things it slowly becomes really
serious and you realize how enormous the
problem is you're like well i'm stuck
now that's it
that's exactly what he was trying to do
so i should say like
getting youtube premium is the like
simple sledgehammer solution it's like
look i'll just
pay the 15 quid just leave me alone i
just want to listen to some music with
the screen off thank you very much yes
if you're willing to put in some time
and you you know you're willing to kind
of get out the paints and
sketch out the the picture the skeleton
first and then
paint it on top and you can put in the
time for it then
alfredo if you've got more money than
time by youtube premium if you've got
more time than money
use eno and alfred the the point of
alfred is that it saves you money long
term but there is a bit of
and i mean obviously this doesn't go
fair for anyone using a windows computer
like that's several steps away just
throwing out what you want to do is is
if you take a computer and go out with
your back door
open up the recycling bin just put it in
there
gently deposit come back to your seat
with a hammer first you forgot the
hammer yeah
uh right my next one is typefully dot
app so i sent this to yusuf yesterday
um if you are someone who uses twitter
and wants to create
long tweet threads from single blocks of
text or from text that's been worked up
into paragraphs
typefully allows you to write out the
entire tweet
thread including previews for urls and
everything else
it brings up a live preview of exactly
how it's going to look on your account
and you don't need to move things around
between the different
threads windows or the tweets within the
thread windows
you can just move the text within a
block a typing block typically like
you'd have on your notes
and it'll automatically do it it won't
cut off halfway between different
sentences
it's all formatted beautifully and then
it's one button to press send
it's like and it's free it's ridiculous
absolutely i mean that solves a problem
that
for many people are like what tweet
threads what's that but
for people that write tweet threads is
it's such a ball ache to
get it all into the right formatting so
not much more to say about that just
typefully.app you should go and check
out if you're a twitter user that uses
tweet threads then
it'll save your life johnny what you got
um this
what's it gonna be i don't know what
welder
yeah i think this is something that you
may have recommended to me chris yeah
some some time ago so they have a kit
which includes
this tub which smells great and that's
part of the benefit of it
and there's a little stick and a little
pumice stone that comes in a in a pack
i used to have a problem i think you've
both seen it actually like
it would happen to me all the time where
i'd be like dead lifting and training
for months
and then a huge callus would go on my
hand
and it would be like i wouldn't be able
to train on it and it would feel like
when you touched your hand you were
touching raw nerve ending it was so
so painful so this stuff i put it on my
desk
and like just before i start work use it
and it's easy to do because it smells
brilliant and
i mean touch wood i've not had any
callous problems since i've been using
it for the people that don't know what
what is the wod welder product what does
the bomb do what's it got in it
uh it's the same thing as funneling it's
lanolin isn't it that's the
thing that like softens your skin so
this is the like the daily cream
and then there's a stick that you put
just on your um
just on your calisteries of your hands
and then there's a pumice stone to like
sand down the uneven edges
so i've only i've never used the cream
and i've never used the pumice stone but
it's like a pritt stick
yeah exactly so that's the it literally
looks like a pritt stick you push it up
from the bottom
and then you just do little circular
motions it does smell awesome
it's fixed it's fixed my hands so
quickly you know when you're doing the
open when the opening used to be six
weeks long
and you'd tear them one week and by the
next week they were
getting back to usable again which is
pretty insane
um yeah i'm wod welders i think you can
buy
it on amazon as well so
i mean just go and buy it on amazon if
you're if you're someone that lifts and
needs to protect your hands and you find
that you're getting callous tan tears
especially anyone that's in crossfit
should already know about this they use
um
what's up it's like smithy's working
hand cream
or something like that and it's one
pound for a huge tub of it from aldi
uh but it just smells like well it
smells exactly as you would think
smithy's
working men's hand cream would smell
like a working man yeah you can use
veterinary udder cream
as well but that's obviously smells like
a veterinary product
it's funny so johnny and i were talking
about this recently where
if you're a power lifter and you think
your calluses are bad like
look at the calluses of a weightlifter
if you're a weight lifter often carson's
bad look at a crossfit and then if you
think your calluses are bad
look at the gymnasts like some of the
the stuff that you see at gymnastics
like people
doing something off the rings and they
just like flap of their palm just off
like i think their fingers half off and
they've
got a tape around it do you not have
this is this not a problem with
gymnastics i've never heard yeah
so so i'm i don't like doing rings very
much i'm not very good at rings and bar
so i just kind of don't do them so for
me floor and
pommel's not really it's not not it's
broken yeah
but always take care of your hands
whenever someone like when i was first
told about like hand care i was like
no i'm not gonna lifting 310 kilos now i
don't need to worry about i'm past hand
care
all right well it's the things you end
up like really valuing
like the skin on your hands stomp like
it's fine
until you can no longer grip something
at all like it's fine until
opening a door hurts and then you're
like okay
it's at the forefront of your experience
as well right like there's nothing
it's the same as having a back injury or
having an aching shoulder or a pulled
neck
it's so there all the time
here i think back pain is the the worst
for that
but anything axial toothache back pain
anything on
along like the midline axis where it is
just that isn't it
in front of the face right what have you
got surf
so this is free advertising for a
different company but
i recently had a steak from block and
bottle
which is a place in the northeast that
does as you can imagine like
craft beers and craft steaks whatever
you call like
boutique steaks everyone in there has
got you know a beard and a plug in their
ear and they're all
you coming in they're like hello sir how
can i help you and oh we have this
particular range of cow today and it's
it's from the the fragrant forests of
azkaban and
this is a story about the meat oh each
piece of meat
incredible and and it's all you know
they've got loads of different
cuts and types of meat and um the
it's it's a bit pricey but it's no more
than you would pay in a restaurant or
something and you when you make it
yourself you just treat it with such
care
and it is beautiful and so
i like a rib eye that's definitely my
top
top choice steak and i'm willing to
fight anyone who disagrees
but ribeye is supposed to be cooked
medium or medium well as opposed to
other
steaks because it's so fatty and you
want the marbling and the
the fat to kind of infuse throughout it
now
the hack is when you
have a fatty cut of steak if you end up
with grisly bits a lot of people throw
that away
but you can just fry it harder at the
end
and you've then just got like because
then it just melts and creates like
new very nice bits you don't want to
waste it
so the hack is don't throw away your
grisly bits just try
frying them hard and see what happens
and order expensive steak
as well yeah so did you have
can you order block and bottle online do
they deliver
possibly it's um they have a they have a
shop with a big queue out the front and
you know you can it's all very
customized it's great experience it's in
heating
okay i've seen a few people talking
about
so i actually saw kino kinobody mention
that
michaela peterson had recommended a meat
delivery company to him yeah she's
sponsored
is it right so i've just seen a few
people like
talking about how they've had steak
delivered so i've just got i've
literally just had reached out to me i
think it's the dry aged
steak co or something have just reached
out to me uh about the show i
i've told them to send some stuff out
and i'll see how it is um
but yeah i think high quality organic
meat people are now
becoming increasingly concerned about
the different antibiotics that are being
pumped into their
food and stuff like that so it doesn't
surprise me that as
carnivore diets become more popular as
people are going keto or low carb
the increasingly high quality meat is
a thing yeah it's not something i i ever
i try and limit the kind of bandwidth
that i spend on
things that i can't control but this is
probably
pushing out the the precipice of like
maybe this is something we should be
looking after because
it was a it was a interview with a
farmer on joe rogan talking about like
a chicken breast in the states costs
like i don't know
1.20 or something and he was like there
is no way that that should cost 1.20
like something
is being something's missing from that
yeah and what's happening is that the
environmental cost is being
um offset so that you can get a chicken
breast for super cheap
but as a result you're getting loads of
yeah antibiotics and fecal matter in the
food and all that kind of stuff
to be able to keep the prices so low and
so his whole idea is like
the farming structure needs to be
completely redone i had chris baber who
is
mns's in-house food chef i had him
on the show a couple of weeks ago and he
was saying the one thing that he always
goes
organic and the highest quality at his
meat he actually says that he goes vegan
two days a week
so that he can afford to go the highest
quality meat for five days
and he would rather do that than have
lower quality meat across the week
he also said another thing which is when
you're eating a steak
you're supposed to use the steak knife
to cut
cross through the fibers as opposed to
long way down the fibers
the reason being that those fibers are
long and stringy and they get stuck in
your teeth and you can
break them up immediately by just
cutting across them and i didn't know
this rule did you guys know this rule
oh okay yeah but i'm a i'm a pretty
sticky man so
um i didn't know i didn't know i knew
that yeah so just
cut across so that you break up the five
the fibers
already and then yeah i
like that uh so yeah cut cut across
um what am i gonna do next okay so i'm
gonna do readwise.io
which is anybody that follows me on
instagram will know that pretty much
every day there's a couple of quotes
that come from a book
and read wise is the service that i use
that delivers me that
so it automatically syncs in with your
kindle and highlights
then it re-delivers you a set number of
highlights at a set time over
email each day if you want to go onto
the website there's a partner app as
well
you can use it as a flash card service
kind of like anki for space repetition
so that you start to actually learn the
insights you've got
you can favorite them you can discard
them you can delete them you can also
upload directly from your kindle
on documents which are not in your
kindle library so let's say that you've
sent a pdf to your
kindle you can do an upload every so
often and they give you a periodic
reminder to say it's been three months
since you plugged your kindle in maybe
you should go and do that
or you can turn it off once you've got
it set up it is
super unintrusive and every single day i
get
four quotes that i've highlighted from
my books from books that i've read
and if you've made notes in kindle as
well so you can highlight something and
then you can make a note if you choose
to so i'm starting to do that as well so
here's something that i think and oh
here's what i think about that thing
right now
and it also includes that it's uh it's
phenomenal
like for remembering the things that you
care about about reading
it's outstanding and um
so you take notes when you while you're
reading and feed it into
read-wise no and it then no so the
highlight that you make
on the kindle yeah yeah it saves that as
soon as you do that it just takes that
but there's also an
option when you highlight something you
can press on it and make a note
in the kindle but you don't need to i do
that very rarely that's maybe like one
in 20.
and it then emails them back to you or
something like that yeah just randomly
randomly picks randomly picks them up
and pulls them through and then as they
come through you can either discard them
or favorite them or just leave them
and i think i have thousands
thousands of highlights now it's pretty
cool it's like every day you just get a
little reminder of something you've read
in the past i get four four
little passages and yeah it
one thing that it's done which i need to
d program is now
sometimes i want to highlight something
because i think it's important in the
book
but i know i i actually start thinking
about how that's going to appear when it
comes up on my read wise i'm like no no
no like you're not highlighting stuff
for read-wise you're highlighting stuff
because it needs highlighted
but um yeah yeah it's it's it's great if
you read
if you use a kindle i think read-wise is
is mandatory
really because it'll just continue to
re-deliver you these
the best bits of books that you've
already been through
you're so deep in the kindle ecosystem i
love it i i i need to do that as well
because i
have but i've just people keep getting
me physical books and
now i've just got to get through them
before i convert you that's a bit of
sweet view i imagine
yeah oh thank you thanks mate
thanks so much right great what
um a hack for
improving a review process so
if anyone listened to chris's interview
with chris sparks
in december end of december
talks about like week uh talks about
monthly reviews
um or quarterly reviews so as we're
recording this
it's like the end of quarter one of 2021
so i always find reviewing you know the
like the standard review questions
like what went well what didn't go well
where the hell do you begin with that
especially if you're like looking back
over a long period of time
again this is something we may have
already covered but it's something
that's been more relevant for me
recently so
i think an easy way to prompt your
memory of what went well and what didn't
go well is look at your
firstly your calendar so if you
have events things that you've done
stuff that you've went like
i mean it's maybe not that good at this
point but generally like people you saw
stuff you did
um highlights and it's really easy to
pick out because you look
at days and you'll be like oh yeah that
was awesome maybe you've completely
forgotten about it until you see it on
the calendar
or like actually that week was rubbish
and here's why so it's a really easy way
you just treat your calendar like a past
record of what happened
and then you've got it ready to go and
saved or
your if you take a lot of photos your
your photo real like your camera reel on
your phone
as a way of just remembering things that
happened or places that you've
been to et cetera so it's just an easier
way to prompt
the memories because i think it's quite
easy to forget things that went well
that didn't go well
so can i just add something to that day
one
have now um they look like they're
moving more in that direction
so they've they're launching deeper
calendar integration
more kind of photos integration and
stuff so that you can basically like
yeah whip through
almost a a museum of your life
what was that thing was it time hop do
you remember time yeah
yeah yeah which was you logged in on all
of your different social media
accounts and it would show you when they
steal all your data and they sell it to
china
and yeah yeah the day one day one does
that already
so whenever you make a new entry in day
one it's like in 2015
on this day you were doing like bloody
hell i
have totally forgotten about that but
it's kind of a different you don't think
like oh yeah
that's helpful to review 2015 you know
so you're saying that
when you're doing a review check your
calendar and your photos because it's a
good prompt
it's just stuff that pro most people so
i know i think yusuf deletes calendar
entries
so some maybe some people do that i
don't know like i personally don't want
once a day
no one does you know you never know so
like
because i'm i'm one of those perverts
that uses a calendar
and calendar events as to do items so
get them on yeah
but yeah so like if like i can look at
january and
remember like key things that happened
um like stuff that i did or stuff that
um but it is more events based and then
photos are things that you
usually if something's memorable or like
interesting most people's reaction at
this point is to take a photo of it
so if you've got that as well it's a way
of like
most people's photo reel on their phone
is like highlights of
stuff that's happened right so it's a
really easy way to to look back
what's the process that you go through
for your quarterly review have you got
have you taken it from somewhere it's
just as simple as that like what went
well what didn't go well
what am i going to do more of what am i
going to do less off have you split that
into
like career health relationships and
other um
yeah i think sometimes like the
categories thing
because that's the struggle i had with
the chris sparks framework is like
there's probably things that at any one
period of your life are like forefront
of the focus so you'll have like a
period of your time where there's a lot
of focus on health or a lot of focus on
relationships
or work so there's not always tons of
stuff in each category
so i tend to just free form it and just
do generally like what do i think is
going well what do i think isn't going
well
and just whatever comes to mind really
to be honest i don't feel very good at
the process like it's something i
struggle with
but i think i think i think most people
do at least you're doing it though man
like i am i even my weekly review on
omnifocus i've said to you before
i'm still struggling to discipline
myself with that because it's just an
arduous task and the desire is always to
do work
not to review and plan work it's like
well i could spend this time planning
and reviewing doing
you're like well no like the reason that
you can do better
is because you've reviewed and planned
so i've got um i've got greg mcewen
coming on the show soon and his new
books effortless
which is all about how you make the
things that you have to do
easier um so i'm looking i've got
i'm a couple of chapters into it and i'm
looking forward to maybe getting
something i was going straight on the
list if someone could buy me the
physical
book version of that please
[Laughter]
just link link to that just before we
move on so with the weekly review thing
i've found and i suppose this isn't
someone you maybe can't always do this
but
we have a in propane we have a meeting
on a monday like a weekly meeting
i know that if i've done my weekly
review
prior to that meeting i'm more i'm
like the meetings more useful it's like
if i've been through everything
then i'm able to like delegate things or
bring things up that i need to talk
about or
actually this is relevant now or
whatever so having it and again it's
hard if you don't have that but
having some kind of accountability if i
do it by this point
then this thing is better it just
because it's never fun
really is it like looking over all of
the projects you have and
trying to decide what's relevant what is
irrelevant like it's not immediately
enjoyable
so if you can add some kind of necessity
to it i've found that really helps
that is that is good to an obvious
explicit
outcome benefit that you're going to
like a line in the sound of like
on monday at 1 45 p.m and it
automatically reviewed yeah
otherwise it's like i'm sat there going
there's anybody going to say
well i would have done if i'd done my
weekly review yeah
oh well you've just told yousef there if
you turn up and you're you stay quiet
for most of the meetings
so i was going to do a physical one but
actually um i think this one's taken the
the the limelight because of what
johnny's just said which is
the apple photos app particularly the
mac version but
they they integrate so well um i've
upgraded to the
the full bells and whistles icloud
storage just because it's
like it's just so smooth now
and i went through a process of you know
a few years ago
when when my dad died and we cleared out
the house there was loads of like
family photos and all that kind of stuff
and there's just like
so much stuff that you get archived and
we've like been arranging to get it
scanned and then you're like oh now i've
just got like folders
of old memories that aren't really doing
anything
so i went through and basically just put
them all into apple photos
still got the rest to be digitized by a
company but
what it allows you to do is it just
makes everything fully searchable
because by the time you've got over a
thousand photos you're never going to be
like looking through them individually
and quite often you want to pick one
for a specific purpose or to make a card
for someone or whatever
and so what apple photos does is you tag
people's faces in it and it links with
your contacts
and then it'll start to recognize more
photos of that person
and also location tags if you took the
photo with your phone
so suddenly rather than having folders
or whatever you've just got a fully
searchable database where you can type
in someone's name
or you can type in like belgium or 2017
or whatever
and it's it's just like the smoothest
experience
so i think if you can learn to leverage
it fully
and also be quite selective about what
you put into apple photos don't just
like
you know when you're out and you take
like 10 photos of someone on a bridge
and you're like or something like
that and then you and you just think
i'll sort them out later or i'll delete
the dodgy ones in a bit
and you never get around to it you need
to make a habit of like
either at the end of the day or just at
the time like
picking the best photo rather than like
leaving
all seven in there it makes like little
video montages as well doesn't it
it's funny oh yeah so there's music over
them yeah
you're you're 20 20.
just a bunch of like selfies
on your own you're looking lonely yeah
existential crises
yeah so what do you use apple photos
for mostly because i don't know about
you
johnny but i very rarely go back through
my photos it's just a
it's a media storage device as far as
i'm concerned for
i'm i'm okay so let me talk you through
because you don't strike me we don't
take a lot of photos when we're together
so
i don't know whether yeah we we don't i
feel like we should take more because
we're
like we're usually having too much fun
to take photos we're going to actually
like it'll be quite a good
so i've got just pretty camps
yeah that's what we need um so i've got
a shared album with my girlfriend so
anytime we're like out somewhere or
whatever and we take some photos we just
both
put them into the shared album and then
we've got a great idea like that's
that's better than the original hack
yeah well
the original hackers just use apple
photos isn't it right
this is a subpac within the hack yeah
and then um
i've got one for like stuff that's
potentially going to go on instagram so
if you have like a good shot that would
be like a pr
kind of photo um so
that kind of thing then you've got ones
organized by
event or location or whatever else
um and so
as a result you can end up oh i've got
one for like testimonials that clients
send us
um one of the property that i'm
working on in developing so it can get
like kind of time lapse
effect so i think using just using the
the tools to its full extent
having a shared album with your partner
is is a good one one thing that i did
when i went away to rome
was get create a shared album between
all of the people that go away on
holiday
yeah there's nothing worse than like 10
people having like such
can you can you air drop me drop me
those ones from today what a what a pain
in the
butt there's so many applications of
that because like every event like
weddings
all these things that you can just
create cloud shared albums
of the consequence if you don't like
claire is going to have some absolute
corker of a photo that she's only sent
to
one person and then like and claire
forgets her icloud login
oh and then that's it right
uh i think that's back of the day would
you reckon the
uh have a shared album with your partner
i think just use use the apple and like
set it up properly
yeah and then everything's easier i'm so
impressed with how much
how much you use your laptop and as
opposed to your phone
yousef like i think i just hate my phone
my thumbs are too fat
but you you've got quite a big one now
you haven't got the tiny little
yeah that's true it's just because the
speed so we we did a test on when we
were recording the podcast of the day
just to demonstrate how much faster
yousef is with a laptop than
most other people so i try to find a
previous episode of a
podcast we've done and i knew what it
was called and i knew where it would be
and it i was still searching it's like
minutes later and you just went but
i think he typed six keys six keys and
the longest
delay was waiting for the laptop yeah so
that's why he doesn't use his phone when
using's quicker than a silicon chip
that's searching for stuff that makes it
yeah like he used to unlock his phone
the time taken for the face id to work
he'd have found it by then
so that's it so i think my phone i
should associate it with like
frustration
like it's taking too long like coming
off a wall
uh right my next one is a quote from
i think it's originally from uh
james clear don't practice what you do
not want to become
and basically it reminds us that there
is no such thing as not instantiating a
habit
you're always embedding some form of
habit
it's either is it the one that you want
to do or is it one that you don't want
to do
there is no oh well this isn't me doing
a thing no no no even not doing your
thing is doing your thing
and do not prac or don't practice what
you do not want to become
is such a lovely little mantra to remind
yourself that
when you're stuck between two choices
between the thing that you know that you
probably
should do and the thing that maybe the
lazy present self is
tempting you to do okay is this
version what i want to become
it almost invariably is going to be no
so it reminds you
to take a third party perspective it
takes you out of your the present self
which is inevitably lazy and takes the
path of least resistance
it's just how do i want
to look back on today tomorrow what
would i
have wanted me to do right now and
almost always you make the right choice
so should i hit the snooze button okay
well do you want to become the sort of
person that regularly hits the snooze
button
because if you hit snooze today not
hitting snooze tomorrow will be harder
not easier the way that yeah
you're right you can't be like oh but
this this doesn't count and you know
kate lachlan says something similar of
you're always practicing something
and so the or i think i heard another
one that's like
there's no this isn't the dress
rehearsal like this is just your life
like you can't be like oh no but
this is the rehearsal so it's fine i'll
just snooze today
it's a scary one it's the it's caving to
the like
mental narrative of like uh like this
time
it's a one-off but tomorrow like
tomorrow next week monday it'll be
different
like that as soon as you fall for that
trick
you're more likely to fall for it every
subsequent time which means you're less
and less likely
forever to do the thing that you're
trying to do and then you're just
drilling the habit of
delaying this time precisely there's
layers and layers of
of how you're talking to yourself and
what the habits are but
the the way that myelin works you don't
get to not lay myelin sheaths down in
your brain
the action that you make will lay down
some sort of pathway
so you might as well decide to reinforce
the ones
of the things that you want to do not
the ones of the things
that you don't want to do if you could
voluntarily like have a timeout button
for your brain that you could turn on or
off
would you have one installed
what would happen so no myelin is laid
down when the timeout is enabled oh god
yeah i just go
crazy i go because that's what people
think is happening when they give
themselves a day off
when they give themselves a right okay
well i'm not going to follow my diet i'm
not going to do my morning routine i'm
not going to train i'm not going to
get up on time that's what they think is
happening they think oh well
yeah but like this is just i'm this
doesn't really count it doesn't matter
when what it is is just another day
that's chipping into the days of good
habits
johnny guys i'm gonna have to go to the
toilet
okay that's fine we can talk yeah we can
talk about you while you go come on
all right cool two seconds it's normally
me as well
at the end of a life hacks my bladder is
barston but
luckily i went for the pre-wee what have
you done this week
i have been finishing up my geriatrics
rotation
what do you want to do next moving on to
a gp practice
which is the the make or break so
interestingly speaking of kind of
productivity i know people
that have performed so well in so
julian for example performed so well in
his gp kind of
entrance application they didn't have to
do an interview and he just got a job
secured on the gp training program
when he did his rotation in gp he sacked
it off
because he was like this is not the kind
of neat
day has clear boundaries kind of
situation that you'd have in a hospital
where you turn up
you handed over some stuff you do the
jobs and then at the end of the day you
hand over to someone else and it's
continuous in gp practice it's like
there's a bunch of stuff that happens on
monday then you've got to follow it up
on the wednesday and you've got to make
right the 50 letters here
and it just opens up a bunch of loops
and it doesn't
get to the you know you you don't have a
clear end to each day so you just got
like this
ongoing massive stuff to do so it'll be
interesting to
see how so will you be a gp for a short
while
gp with a lot of support so i'm i'm i'll
be a
an f2 doctor so like having my own
patient load but
with a with a special gp to go and ask
if i'm
stuck about anything it's usually
administrative stuff it's like
oh how do you refer to this particular
clinic or
who do you send this person to or
whatever the
hierarchy of medicine is insane when you
realize just how
long and drawn out it is that the people
who've been studying for five years and
then on placement for two
still basically just get to file the
paperwork for the people that are fully
qualified
it yeah it depends on the specialty um
if you're in something super specialized
then that's definitely the case
um or if you you know if it's surgery
then you're gonna be very gradually
which is great for the for the
you know for the patient because you're
never going to be operated on by someone
who's just yellowing the procedure
at two in the morning our cousin joanne
who's here on placement
[Laughter]
well she was great in the hairdressers
joanne do you mind just filling in
because this uh this woman needs uh
appendix taken off all right i'll give
it a go
[ __ ] help so i watched that um is it
three identical strangers
about those twins in new york that was
separated at birth
adopted and then if you haven't watched
it three identical strangers on netflix
is
amazing very heartwarming um
documentary it's it's a great watch and
i won't spoil it for you but
um these three guys get separated
and then they they come back and find
each other at like 19 years old
and they're triplets and one of the guys
one of the guys they start living
together after a few years one of the
dudes needs his appendix taken out he's
got appendicitis
but he doesn't have any medical
insurance so he goes into the hospital
under his brother's name
who does have medical insurance and gets
his appendix taken out
under the name of his identical brother
although surely you could do that with
anyone like or
in the states do they have like photo id
i think they check almost definitely
a photo id for medical stuff because
it's all done on
it's all that everyone's got to have an
insurance policy don't they i feel like
it was just saying like oh this is my
name
honest promise like there'd be a lot of
fraud going on i feel like you could do
that in the uk couldn't you
i mean i've not tested the limits of the
fraud i think it's quite hard
what you got blob okay um
it's the question of which which
direction to take things in
how many more are we doing we got a bit
of time we'll be doing at least at least
a couple each
okay so in that case
this is a diet related hack which is low
calorie hot chocolate
what is the because i might is it just
less of the spoons in or is it the same
number of spoons
but it's lower calorie i don't really
have like normal hot chocolate so i
don't know but
it's a it's an easy it's just like 60
calories
so they get to the end of the day you've
hit your calories for the day
and you think like i really would just
quite like something
sweet it's negligible
like wouldn't you be tracking it there's
a
i think it's galaxy chocolate do like a
60 calorie one so if you're dieting
it's just a really easy thing to have to
add in at the end of the day
i wonder what a normal scoop of hot
chocolate is
i think they're pretty high calorie is
that right yeah the number of spoons
that's the thing that's why i'm so
surprised that
because it's like what is the bulk of
the stuff if it's it'll be
awful and artificial and like i wouldn't
it's not like a healthy drink filled
with carcinogens isn't it yeah
have you tried other ones or is the
galaxy is the galaxy the only one that
you've tried
it's i've only tried one yeah like i'm
not to be honest i'm not
i'm not looking for like the the edge
with it it's it's something that that
just takes a box
yeah had um
cognac noodles yes on conjuring
the the low the low calorie like
rubberized noodles
they're like two calories per pound yeah
that's pretty mean it's not food is it
yeah it's just bulk yeah i like
you you eat it and you think i shouldn't
be eating this
like this this feels like if i would eat
my
pencils or something yeah like but i
think when you're deep in a diet when
you're like
you can start to see pancreas secreting
insulin you're just like yeah give me it
yeah
anything yeah anything to feel
mechanically full i'll
i'll eat whether it's like tissue paper
noodles
space isn't it low calorie hot chocolate
man i think
that and zero calorie jelly or low
calorie jelly
all of these little ways to the
um charity popcorn the low calorie
charity popcorn as well all just little
things that you can
chip away also like um like fruit
fruit juice lollies you know like a
like a ice cream not an ice cream but
you know what i mean like you both know
what i mean
yeah um those but like uh an orange
juice one they're also really a calorie
same sort of thing are you dieting at
the moment i yeah i
am what are you going to throw into
i was when i started i was 106 kilos
i'm now 96 kilos
that's the plan yeah [ __ ] i want to be
within firing range of the 93 so i want
to be like
95 and under and then i just want to nip
in and
put my deadlift record up again you're
such a terminator at 93.
what are you working toward here when
are you working towards peaking for
and starting later this year like that
i'm just
like enjoying training and being a bit
lighter and
it's uh it's quite a big difference
being
what's the difference what's the
difference between being 106 kilos and
96 kilos
just like the general effort of life
is slightly lower across the board so
like
walking uh any any exertion
is easier because obviously this like
imagine carrying a 10 kilo plate like if
i gave you a 10 kilo plate so you've got
to take this with you everywhere you go
you can't leave it anywhere like if you
go to the shop and leave it on there
on the checkout you've got to go back
and get it yeah you've got to have it
with you the whole time
it's so funny like i i remember the kind
of experiencing the opposite of that
like because i went from 59 to 90 kilos
in about four or five months yeah and
yeah
you get like a pump in your lower back
going upstairs and like
shin splints just from like less than
15 minutes running awful you just feel
worse in every way structurally
unadapted
to your own body somehow yeah well
especially if it happens quickly so i
gained like i gained my
my 10 kilos i gave my 10 kilo plate over
like
six months so not quite as aggressive as
as uh
as yusuf but this would be the lightness
that you've been for ages then
the lightest i've been since 2017. wow
that's awesome man congratulations
thanks man
seth what you got let me know if i've
said this one
before but it's keys in the fridge yeah
i have said this before yeah really okay
so
in that case let's switch to speaking of
the
high so that for anyone doesn't know
what that is it's probably three
episodes back
um speaking of 170 bpm
music french core is the one
french core it's it's such a great job
to find
so for anyone that enjoys a bit of kind
of
edm music and things ah but i just wish
it was
just twice as fast and a bit more
distorted
and i wish it just like blew my head off
a bit more
french core is the one have a listen to
bill x
dr peacock and suffer and they will
change your life
so interestingly yousef i listened to
some doctor peacock the other day
did you i think it's because you tagged
him
oh yeah i think something on instagram
he's actually saw the like message
thread and i listened to his latest like
viking
trance one yeah viking dance or some
something like that welcome to valhalla
that's it yeah yeah it was nearly there
um
i liked it more than i thought it's it's
a gateway drug it is a bit much though
isn't it
it's the kind of thing that you you hear
what it's like eating a spicy chili
and you're like oh that's that's too
much for me and then like a day later
you're like
how would you describe the sound of
listening to it johnny
so it feels like there's a lot of noise
so there's a wall of noise that hits you
and there's a there's a hint of a of a
melody there and someone shouts the word
melody next door
it's the lacroix if
i almost find myself like wanting the
melody to continue
like and then it starts getting a bit
more like
oh okay and then so like i think
listening to it's like a
there's a mental strain to listening to
it for me
what a description it's yeah it pushes
your limits it
i i find it beautiful like gaba brings
me to tears
absolutely beautiful beautiful yeah but
there's no melody
that's the point i think that says so
much about you as a human
i think it's just matching your mental
overclocked brain yeah
precisely shut down
that's binaural beats that's yousef
binaural beats it's noise cancelling
for brain isn't it but like
so similarly i i'll listen to music that
has a lot of shouting in it i suppose
it's the only way to describe
this and i'll play with other people and
they'll hate it
and they'll say why do you like it well
i don't really know like you can't
really hear what they're saying
he sounds pretty annoyed about something
crazy
upset at best yeah he's vexed about
something but you can't
understand what but i really like it for
some reason
and it's like you know when you meet
someone who has a similar music taste
you don't
there's just an interesting oh yeah
you don't like i'd hear that like oh
yeah yeah and have you heard that album
oh yeah
do you have that with dr peacock do you
ever meet
fellow dr peacockers yeah so um i've got
a friend who's a vet
who absolutely loves that the problem is
a lot of
he he's more on the like happy hardcore
kind of side of it
um but the problem is in the sky side
but yeah but turned up
the speed the problem is um a lot of the
those kind of happy hardcore stuff on
youtube seems to have like
hentai as the thumbnails and he says
that he just plays it while he's in
surgical theater and sometimes like his
colleagues will be like
what what have you got on there he's
like oh no it's just the music it's not
the
it's not nudie anime right yeah [ __ ]
right uh this is one that all of us will
do
i'm almost certain but we haven't put it
on the life hacks before which is answer
emails when you're waiting for something
so
if you are sat waiting for food to be
delivered outside of a
restaurant or you've gone to the
mechanics and your car's getting done
there's a number of different things
that you could do you could browse the
internet you could look on social media
but inevitably there's always a bunch of
emails that you need to
you need to get through maybe you've got
a bunch of different inboxes maybe
you've got like a public facing inbox
that you need to
you batch it once every couple of weeks
or something like that
and um the beauty of
using time where life thinks
it's got you to actually get it you're
like no no
no no you don't make me wait you don't
make me wait i'm
i'm going to stop me waiting in real
life when you're making me wait in this
mechanics place at quick fit
the old switcheroo yeah exactly and um
you know i just think it's especially
we've got this image of chris
quick fit just going
are you smirking i'm hoping that the
thought process has spoken out
like ah life
today my friend i'm afraid it's going to
be a 20-minute wait
no problem sir don't you worry your good
friend
yeah i am answer your emails when you're
waiting for stuff just
you can just tick through them slowly
move through whatever it is
you can't do the complex ones that need
opening up a google doc and referring to
stuff i know can you send over the
attachments for whatever
but the vast majority of emails aren't
that the vast majority of emails are
just you confirming that you've received
an email from someone or
what's your address what's your email
whatever stuff it might be
and um yeah just chew through that i've
found
because when you're waiting there's an
upper bound i think on how
cognitively complex the things are that
you can do i don't think that you would
be able to oh i'll write the sales copy
for my new thing or i'll update my cv
like you're not going to be able to sync
yourself into a deep state yeah
precisely
but the vast majority of email work
isn't deep it's just
shallow and frequent so answer your
emails when you're waiting for sure
have you ever said i hope this email
finds you well
i've said hope hope you're well
yeah i've never said i think email finds
you well that seems a bit i think that's
one of the weirdest things to say but
people do it all the time
like when it finds you well i say is it
like
is it when it finds you that you're well
or is it i hope it finds you on the
internet
and it locates you effectively yeah
yeah as opposed to unwell
i don't know i i wonder about people
that use the term e-meet
yeah definitely i don't know what i
think about them but i think something
about them
i haven't decided what i think about
them yet nice to e-meet you
yeah it's just it needs a better word
doesn't it because the
the phrase itself is cringy but i
understand the sentiment
so it needs a cooler sounding the better
one the best one the one that i always
use is just great to connect
that seems like it's a bit yeah it's
very trade linkedin outreach isn't it i
don't use linkedin
you'd love it on linkedin oh god so
here's something that this is a greater
connect chris
this is like using a um like using some
racial slur that you've never heard
before and
no no no that's what that's what mum and
dad used to call my favorite bear
you're gonna you can't call it that you
can't
call it that exactly you've been invited
to a linkedin
best-selling author speaking gig yeah
just because of what you said
most great to connect in 2021
right johnny johnny johnny what you got
johann i can probably do one more
why don't we do one more and then
whatever you've watched on netflix
recently that's been best
cool so mine is
instead of a process goal
have a mini win goal so
i imagine everyone's probably heard the
james clear thing of like
it's not an outcome goal it's a process
goal and then you set a process google
and you try and do the process and you
get bored of it about
20 days in and stop doing the process
and i think like i've
i've been trying a lot to make the just
the things that i do
easier and more enjoyable and simpler
and then you can just forget about
because i think that's the best place to
be isn't it like when you're doing
something when you're when something is
the right thing to do
and you do it without really thinking
about it i think that's the best place
to be in
so the stuff that i'm really consistent
at
i'm consistent at it because i'm always
chasing a little a little pb like a
little goal
which attaches to the process but the
process gets you there
but the thing that i pay attention to is
like the the mini win that maybe happens
weekly or monthly or whatever
so like for training it might be my like
estimated one rep max or for
propane it might be the number of
podcast downloads in a week or whatever
it is like it's not necessarily relevant
it's not the thing that the overall
thing that you're chasing but if you can
just focus on the little things it gives
you that little
dopamine kick of like yeah yeah yeah
this is fun this is from more of this
and in the meantime you're just being
really consistent with the
stuff that would otherwise be quite
boring if you just weren't looking at
anything
so i largely forget so like link back to
your question before like what am i
aiming for
in training like at the moment nothing
really but the little
the little pbs are enough to to keep me
coming back
so if you can finding the
equivalence in stuff you're trying to be
consistent with
can be really helpful i think that's
cool i think
everybody intuitively does that right
even when you
stop thinking about the main goal you're
always watching whatever the
little attributes or metrics are that
take you a long way to that
the stuff that you don't think about it
in will be the stuff that you're
inconsistent
i imagine what is other than training in
propane have you got any other
examples of well i guess weight loss
would be one
like you can just look at your average
average monthly weight loss on the way
to losing
13 kilos from 106 to 93. it's yeah just
hitting like a new
a new low weigh-in is enough like it
doesn't really matter what that number
is but if it's like the lowest one
you've hit
that's cool like that's enough to kind
of keep you consistent um
with meditating i tried like tracking
the numbers i think
you and i both use the same approach
crystal like no the noting
method the shinzen young approach just
rather than thinking um like feel or
hear or see it's a number so i just
think like
sensation noted that's one two three
and then just thinking oh like this week
i hit a like a streak of that
unbroken focus that i've not hit before
it's the same practice
but that compared to kind of just
sitting and trying to like subjectively
think well is it better or worse or is
it working
just little ways to like i think i'm
very aware of the fact that i'm i'm very
focused on
like hitting these little wins or pbs i
seem to be wired that way
you're a metrics driven guy like yeah
yeah a chartered
chartered accountant economics graduate
like you know who's inevitably going to
be this way
like hitting numbers like stats to prove
that things move in the right direction
so if that's kind of what the kick i get
out of stuff and i can wire myself that
way and in the background just be doing
the
things that are consistently good for me
in five years time
then that's a win overall so like find
have a mini win goal
for stuff you're struggling with rather
than a i'm going to meditate for 30 days
because at some point in the 30 days
you'll get bored
more than likely but if you're trying to
hit like little
little pbs even if it's a streak goal
like that should that helps you be
consistent with the thing that you're
probably struggling with
that's a really good one i like that a
lot seth what you got
again i don't know if i've done this one
before and
this is because my ticking off process
has not been very
good for the last lifehack so i've got a
lot of open boxes that may or may not
have been mentioned
but this is about gift technique
so partly using the apple ecosystem
so when you have a person in your life
put their birthday
in their apple contact card
and in the notes section put lots of
potential gift ideas
so i have two systems for this one of
them is a
note on evernote that's just like
general gift ideas that would be good
for anyone
that are generic not specific to a
certain person
and then if you have ones that are
specific to a person you put it in their
apple contact
that way you have a reminder if you want
to be extra
good about it you can set a reminder
like a week before the birthday or
whatever
and then the next hack is to whenever
you
get a gift for someone's birthday or
christmas or whatever
double up get another one too if it's a
generic gift just buy two of them and
store it somewhere in case you
caught out and you need you need to get
some chocolates or whatever for someone
or get the thing for their next
event as well so this is if you're big
on birthdays and christmas
personally i've not actually been very
good at doing this in action but i know
that it would just solve a lot of
stress i don't actually like birthdays
and christmas as
things i think they are it's it's like
if you don't get them a present it's
considered a social faux pas
but if you do get them a present like
there's a ceiling on how good it can be
whereas i think impromptu just random
presents
are always going to be much better
received and much more heartfelt
so there's an argument to say sack off
birthdays and christmas entirely
and just get people random presents well
that's the way that
slot machines work right they're a
variable schedule reward
that's precisely why it's addictive and
why it feels good because you don't know
when it's going to come
yeah well yeah and there's another
social layer of it as well which is like
if you don't get your girlfriend flowers
on valentine's day or something
she might be a bit upset but if you get
her flowers on a random day
she'll be so much more pleased than she
would be
upset if you didn't on valentine's day
well i think i think you keep on dating
quite balanced girls
um i think i think there is a subset of
both men and women out there who would
lose their [ __ ] if they didn't get a
birthday present but received two random
presents throughout the year uh
interesting okay uh right my
last one before we do a quick round of
what we've watched on netflix is
kings of the wild that's w-y-l-d
so i got introduced to this book by a
buddy called jake who's big into fantasy
it's a fiction book it's 350 400 pages
long it'll take you maybe
a few weeks if you read for 15 minutes a
night or 30 minutes a night it'll
take you a few weeks to read it's just
very
easy to go through super fast-paced
really compelling characters everyone
that i've given red rising to which i
mentioned a few life hacks ago
got completely addicted including your
housemate chris
i so i got him it on your recommendation
and he devoured it and he ended up
buying the next like
four or whatever yeah so i mean what
what a
like that's when you know you've hit a
home run with a gift when the person
goes and gets
the subsequent gifts within the yeah so
um red rising if you missed that one on
on the life hacks a couple of
episodes ago but kings of the wild
in short in this new world
mercenary bands uh mercenary teams
of people are treated like bands like
rock bands so they go and do
tours where they compete in arenas and
kill monsters they have groupies
um they all have different types of
weapons like one will have a sword but
this
the guy that's got the axe is obviously
kind of the front man with the guitar
the guy that's got the two the double
swords is obviously the drummer
um and it's just a it's super fast-paced
there's a little bit i would say that
the character development's a tiny
little bit shallow
but what you lose in terms of the depth
of character development you pick up
because the story just doesn't stop it
just keeps on going there's always
they're in a new place within no time at
all like you'll just they'll need to get
somewhere and then randomly
there'll be a flying dragon or whatever
they can attack and then they'll get
there so it's just
it's really good it's an easy read and
it's i enjoyed it so
red rising if you haven't got it already
and kings of the wild if you need a new
book
johnny what have you watched recently i
need to go very soon so the stuff to be
quick that's cool um
but my it's not on netflix it's on
sky atlantic or now tv if you have now
tv but it's called you've been going for
some
niche um sources of media recently
it's just now tv now tv apple tv
um sky atlantic i mean you
i think we just heard that between me
and my girlfriend we just have all of
the
available every membership instead of
getting sky we just have
we pay like a third of the sky
subscription and have more of the
available tv
what have you watched so it's called
your honor
it's directed by brian cranston of
breaking bad fame
i know you suffocate like a bit of
breaking bad
um it's it's fantastic so like the plot
in summary is
he is a judge very well known judge his
son basically runs over
the uh son of a
famous mob boss and the things that
unravel as a result of that and it is
brilliant
you couldn't recognize i love tv shows
where
mental [ __ ] happens to normal people
do i well what about uh not fargo
what was the one jacob's thingy no what
was the thing
with apologizing to jacob defending
jacob no
the one the one with the guy who gets
caught up doing accountants for drugs
drug runners yeah that's class
so my girlfriend has this theory that i
like
uh films and tv shows with powerful men
in
i'd say to be honest it's it's the case
so like the so picky blinders
i think like every so there is this
theory that the stuff that you like
is the stuff that you want to see
yourself as the character the main
character right so
he's a financial advisor um gus from
breaking bad is like a very quantitative
business man
they're all very yeah numbersy yeah
he's not numbersy in your honor i
watched the first episode i walked into
my housemate watching the first episode
the other day it's pretty good i thought
the first episode was actually a little
bit slow
but i'm gonna guess give it time chris
give it time sure thing time
seth what have you watched recently so
have you ever like
just you're eating something and you
just put something on thinking i'll just
like whatever i'll just put this on like
and then you end up just falling through
all three seasons of it and you're like
oh
god what am i done um that was the fall
i told you this was on a life hack a
while ago i told you to watch this
did you right was it on your list yeah
so yeah that's where it's come from
what i need to do is start attributing
on the list like who recommended this i
want because
i want the associated phrase thank you
yeah yeah so
so basically i watched it on chris's
recommendation without realizing like it
was i'll put something on okay someone
said
it's that's back to the beginning the
ultimate life access doesn't it
yeah that's true also it literally is
um very good it's for people that are
listening it's about a pervert
pervert um of it
but well that's what we it's because
we've been just calling it
part of it because i know i know an
egyptian doctor who
was talking about someone who's like
this man is perfect
and so we've just been calling it
pedophile and actually forgot what the
original show was um so yeah it's about
a pervert and his evolution of
thought and action very interesting i
like the fact it's quite subversive
like you don't know what's going to
happen it kind of
breaks a lot of the norms that's why
i've said it before but line of duty
of which the new season is currently
airing line of duty
does not it gets a samurai sword out and
kicks you in the balls
like that's the way that's
yeah i think probably the most similar
yeah there's a lot of like baby tape
bbc drama it's classic isn't it like
both of them are
um like sunday night 9pm bbc drama
but you'd think like typically you'd
have thought that would have just been
yeah crap like filmed on someone's vhs
camera
the actors would have been awful right
so i'm gonna try and rattle off a couple
so
three identical strangers is a
documentary
that maybe about two hours long you need
to watch that
um unforgotten have you seen this
yeah so unforgotten is a little bit like
a slightly diluted down version of line
of duty
um but still that's a compliment
have you seen the latest series yes
very good isn't it yeah yeah the latest
in the ending of the latest series
yes yeah yeah seriously that's all we
need to say isn't it yeah so
three identical strangers unforgotten
and i have got another one
and i can't remember it it'll it'll come
back to me at some point in the future
your honor the full three identical
strangers and unforgotten i mean that's
that's enough to get to get anybody
through i watched the staircase
we i suppose yeah it's a mental thing
happening to normal people isn't it
so the the staircase is is good because
it just doesn't stop
yeah what what an ordeal it's the the
clip where he's sat in the room
and the lawyer's like listing off how
much it's going to cost
and he's just sat over his glasses going
like his eyebrows are always up
he's getting taken to cleaners it's like
it could cost him like 750 grand
to defend himself i mean he defends
himself over decades
so it's not it's not really that
surprising the thing with that program
is
if like if it's the case that she just
fell down the stairs
like for [ __ ] he must just be like this
is ridiculous
actually that's to be fair that's
probably the biggest
indication of his guilt that he's just
not more indignant
like i would be so put out can you
imagine if youssif had to put
up with a decade of paperwork
you just stand up and you're kidding me
this is ridiculous
things to do have you seen the state of
my tick tick right just
[Music]
fell down the stairs i'm very upset
about it but that's not enough
leave me alone oh
right guys i am going to have to go
that's fine look gentlemen
thank you we will do this again soon
everybody that is listening all the
stuff that we've gone through will be
linked in the show notes below
if you have any life hacks that you want
to submit if they're phenomenal then we
might consider putting them on
i think over the entire career of life
hacks we've featured maybe two or three
audience suggestions so throw them in
the comments below and see if you can
get them done but
for now it is propane fitness.com
modern wisdom for the seven things you
won't believe about how to launch an
online business
you won't believe what johnny says at
number four and then what's the one that
are you still running the free webinar
that is that well yeah just go to that
one it's all the same now
so beautiful that's right guys have a
good weekend i'll catch you later
on see ya peace thank you very much for
tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace